Even as CBS’ "Mom" lost one of its biggest
stars, the show still pulled off a season
finale viewers can be satisfied with. Here's how
the characters came through their darkest times.
As a heart-warming sitcom that never gets
cheesy, "Mom" is a rare beast. This isn't
an easy trick for a show that often features
multiple AA meetings per episode. A big part
of what keeps the humor of "Mom" from being
hackneyed is the way it honors the recovery
process. "Mom" understands the careful balance of
hope, grit, and focus necessary to staying sober.
As it turns out, substance abuse is a
matter close to the heart of the show's
creative team. Cast member Kristen Johnston has
reflected on her own history with addiction,
as per Today, and producer Chuck
Lorre has made it clear how important
he believes the show's message is in
our modern world. Lorre told Variety.
"Women helping women recover from the seemingly
hopeless disease of alcohol and drug addiction
provided this extraordinary ensemble of
great actresses […] In loving each other
and supporting each other, they survive not as
individuals—the me is overridden by the we."
That "we" encompasses the stacked ensemble cast of
"Mom," also includes Mimi Kennedy, Jaime Pressly,
Beth Hall, and William Fichtner. Every episode
uses hope and humor to navigate the lives of
women in recovery, and the final season is
no different. The show draws to a close by
admitting the struggle is very real—but
so are the friends made along the way.
While she isn't physically present in
Season 8 of "Mom," Christy still has a
relationship with Bonnie throughout it.
Bonnie even fondly jokes about Christy
in the moving finale. Viewers get a sense
that Christy and Bonnie are on good terms,
even though Christy is busy at
Georgetown Law. While this casual
camaraderie might seem typical for a sitcom,
it's downright miraculous for the Plunketts.
"I don't like you, but we eat
eight meals a week together."
Most of this show's humor comes from Christy
and Bonnie butting heads. The mother-daughter
duo are an odd couple: Christy constantly
searches for approval and a steady path,
while Bonnie blazes a self-serving trail through
any and all situations. But Christy's meekness can
easily shift to rage against Bonnie, just like
Bonnie's air of confidence can be rattled by
the slightest judgment from her daughter. These
leading ladies are a comedy dream team, as well
as a vivid portrait of living and forgiving in
recovery. No matter how much progress either mom
makes, they can always remind each other of the
consequences of their chaotic pasts. This keeps
them on their toes and in check—when they aren't
screaming at each other or smuggling maple syrup
across the Canadian border, anyway. But when
Christy takes the next step in her healing
journey all the way to law school, she leaves
Bonnie to assume her own new role: den mother.
Though "Mom" initially focuses on Christy, it ends
as an ensemble show led by Bonnie. While Bonnie
loves the attention that comes with being the AA
gang's de facto leader, she doesn't always love
the responsibility it requires. This is evidenced
when she lies her way into booking business for
her and Tammy, bullies Marjorie into attending a
slumber party, and unintentionally makes everyone
confront something traumatic from their past, and
mocks new sponsee Rod, played by Steve Valentine,
for not remembering a passionate weekend they
spent together during his rock star days.
"You don't forget me. I forget you."
But the ending of "Mom" shows Bonnie is the
glue holding her band of ladies together—and
a dauntless crusader. Season 8 sees her
get a sleazy strip club owner to take down
a 20-year-old billboard of Christy, spur her
ADHD therapist into asking out an old crush,
and throw out her roast of Marjorie in favor
of a heartfelt speech. When Bonnie isn't
terrifying Adam and the gals with her wrath,
she's helping them stay on track and grow.
Allison Janney is one of the finest actors of our
time. Known for her work on "The West Wing," "I,
Tonya," and "10 Things I Hate About You,"
she won two Emmys for her performance on
"Mom." Janney can pull off heart-wrenching
moments of vulnerability and slapstick
silliness—and on "Mom," both are often required
in lightning-quick scenes. It's only appropriate,
then, that her finale co-star is another
powerhouse performer: Melanie Lynskey.
The "Mom" finale features the "Yellowjackets"
star as Shannon. Shannon is brand-new to recovery
and mistrustful of Bonnie's shiny, happy AA
gang, who are in particularly smiley form at
the start of the episode. When Bonnie clocks
that Shannon definitely isn't feeling it,
she chases after her through the rain, ruining
her new suede shoes in the process. This sacrifice
isn't typical of the old Bonnie, but we get the
sense that it might be what the new-and-improved
version is all about. Bonnie ultimately
convinces Shannon to get coffee with the gang.
"What is it with you people and coffee?"
"It's the only drug we have left, so we abuse it."
These evenly matched actresses set a strong
and poetic tone for the end of the series,
and create a final showdown between
a stand-in mother and daughter.
"And life possibly changing in five, four, three."
"Don't do that voice."
"Roger that."
Bonnie sees a lot of herself in
Shannon—especially her bad attitude and sense
of being marked for failure. While we've seen
Bonnie try to play the hero before, this time,
she manages to put her ego aside and calmly
tell Shannon she can call any time she's
tempted to use. Just like the old Bonnie,
Shannon is convinced she doesn't need, or
deserve, real help, and brushes the offer off.
But later, she comes begging for aid–just
as Bonnie, stressed by news of Adam's cancer
diagnosis, struggles to give it. Bonnie is
rattled, and becomes even more so when Jill
reveals she and Andy are getting married
right away and want Bonnie to attend. And
then Shannon's mom chases Shannon through a
window. When Bonnie can't get hold of Shannon,
a pit forms in her stomach. Has Shannon met
the same fate as Jodi? Chaos reigns—the exact
kind that would have driven the old Bonnie to
drink. We've seen old Bonnie relapse before.
But this time, she doesn't. Instead, she
works hard to support Shannon and Adam.
Bonnie ends up pulling some strings
to get the brawling Jolene and Shannon
contained at Jill and Andy's courthouse
wedding—and their first mother-daughter
AA meeting. When Bonnie addresses
the room with her moving final share,
we see an echo of her and Christy in Shannon and
Jolene. This makes it clear how far she's come.
While the AA meetings of "Mom" see
their fair share of guest stars,
Marjorie is on the show from Episode 1. Mimi
Kennedy portrays the eccentric hippie with a
nuanced mix of tenderness and tenacity.
Marjorie is more than her love of cats
and velour tracksuits—she's struggled
with addiction, feelings of failure,
and motherhood. But with Bonnie and the
gang by her side, she gets a second chance.
"Mom" celebrates Marjorie's long road to
reconnection with her son in the Season
8 episode "A Community Hero and a Wide Turn."
Marjorie is nominated for a leadership award,
and soon discovers her formerly-estranged
son nominated her. They share a touching,
full-circle moment, which is made
even more satisfying by the fact
that Marjorie misses the awards ceremony
to provide support to a pregnant Jill.
"Mom" also delivers another poignant moment
between Marjorie and sponsee Bonnie in the
series finale, "My Kinda People and the Big
To-Do." While Bonnie often makes cracks about
Marjorie in the same breath as asking her for
help, in the finale, she's as straightforward
as we've ever seen her. She reaches out in a time
of need, and Marjorie advises Bonnie that all she
can do is "the next right action," leaving
the audience with a powerful final message.
Comedy legend Kristen Johnston plays Tammy,
Bonnie's friend and business partner. At
first blush, you'd never guess Tammy held up a
restaurant on "Cops Eat Free" night, back when
she was using. Tammy starts her journey on "Mom"
searching for a family that won't fracture. Her
own father murdered her mother, leaving Tammy
to bounce around the foster care system. She
spent some formative years with Bonnie and a
few years in prison. But by Season 8 of "Mom,"
she's a far cry from the person she once was.
She has made amends with the steakhouse owner,
and even has a sweet and handsome limo driver
boyfriend. Tammy's story arc sees her learn how
to find hope and joy without substances
and finally find a family worthy of her.
Johnston is familiar with the recovery process.
She wrote a memoir about her experience, called
"Guts: The Endless Follies and Tiny Triumphs of
a Giant Disaster." She told The New York Post,
"I love being sober and the recovery
community. It has given me such
great gifts. And I count this job [on
'Mom'] as one of them, I really do."
No character provides as much extra comic
relief on "Mom" as the unspeakably rich Jill,
played by Jaime Pressly. Jill's vanity and
materialism are matched only by her desire
to prettify her own pain and her longing
to escape her haunted past. Jill blames her
perfectionism for her bad luck in love, but
in the final season of "Mom," she gets more
than she bargained for in that arena. Jill finally
allows herself genuine joy in the series finale.
She's lived a lifetime masking her pain over her
mother's death, her trouble conceiving a child,
her bittersweet fostering experience, and
her divorce. But while she often struggles
with going with the flow of life, rather than
trying to control every inch of it, the finale
of "Mom" sees her accept herself and her life as
a joyful mess. She marries Andy in a courthouse
while visibly pregnant, as two grown women
brawl behind her—and she couldn't be happier.
Wendy, played by Beth Hall, is perhaps the
greatest enigma on "Mom," and not all of
her mysteries are unraveled by the series
finale. Wendy's emotionality and randomness
are stronger than any other character's on the
show, earning her many puzzled looks from the
gang across the AA meeting room. While it isn't
always apparent what's on Wendy's mind, her final
season story arc sees her get out from under the
shadow of her friends and into her own light.
"That's right, I'm funny."
"Weeping Wendy" has learned to regulate
her emotions significantly by the time
the series ends. Often the show's most
sidelined character, Wendy has learned
how to stand on her own two feet by the
finale, and help others learn to find the
same footing. Instead of working herself to
death at the hospital and using substances
to push through, Wendy closes the series
as a rock-steady leader of the program.
While we're used to seeing Wendy in the
background of group shots, our final image
of her is a woman who stands tall behind the AA
podium. She asks both the room and the audience,
"Who else would like to share?"
Adam lived life on the wild side, until he lost
the use of his legs. As Bonnie's new husband,
he lives on a different wild side. Adam is
the straight man to Bonnie's scheming clown,
and a charming, challenging, stabilizing
force. For all of Bonnie's lioness qualities,
her relationship with Adam
spotlights her tender underbelly.
When Bonnie confronts her fear of
abandonment, deep-seated insecurities,
and potential for growth, it's often because
of Adam's encouragement—or because Bonnie is
in the midst of a panic spiral about his safety.
William Fichtner's pitch-perfect comic timing and
dry-as-a-bone delivery always sets Bonnie
to rights. But when Adam and Bonnie learn
of his cancer diagnosis in the finale, Adam is
suddenly the one in need of a stabilizing force.
Bonnie, however shakily, steps up to support
Adam in this climactic moment. She's a rock
to her husband at the doctor's office—and
a blunt force object against his doctor's
poor fish tank cleaning standards. When she
insists they'll get through this together,
the otherwise numb Adam is truly
comforted. And she's going to make
sure the team takes whatever the next
right step is, over and over again.
The ending of "Mom" mirrors its beginning,
and re-ups the show's thesis statement:
Recovery is possible, even if relapse is
probable. "Mom" proposes that those who
desire redemption and rebirth through
recovery deserve it and can earn it if
they work for it. They don't have to do it
alone, either. "Mom" finds recovery within
supportive and loving communities. Bonnie
delivers a powerful share in the finale,
addressing her friends and the group's
dysfunctional new mother-daughter duo.
She admits that despite the reasons she could
have a drink, she doesn't. Why? She offers,
"I kind of like me. I kind of love me."
It's a moving distillation
of growth and acceptance,
and we see it across the show's beloved ensemble.
Though the finale leaves unanswered questions,
we know Bonnie's going to be okay as long as she
keeps working for it—with help from her friends.